pour venir en aide à ses enfants
plusieurs approches une approche
j'allais dire locale avec des ONG on le
verra dans quelques instants avec
Monsieur Tardieu qui est avec nous et
puis les approches plus mondiales avec
l'UNICEF Claire Brisset est avec nous on
leur remercie vous êtes directrice de
l'information de l'UNICEF alors vous
votre objectif final si je puis dire
c'est l'éradication complète du travail
des enfants dans le monde à terme c'est
bien entendu ce qu'il faut obtenir il
faut être réaliste aussi donc déterminer
plutôt deux stratégies deux types de
stratégie la première c'est de supprimer
immédiatement tout ce qui est absolument
toxique pour les enfants c'est à dire
tout ce qui les met en danger tout ce
qui est dangereux la prostitution vous
l'avez cité mais d'autres travaux qui
mettent leur vie en danger moi j'ai vu
des ateliers ou l'expérience l'espérance
de vie des enfants et de 20 ans ça ça
doit s'arrêter immédiatement pour les
autres pour les autres il faut mettre au
point une stratégie d'éradication
progressive on se doute bien que 250
millions d'enfants n'avons pas retourné
à l'école demain mais si l'objectif
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en
attendant avec les enfants qui sont déjà
au travail et bien il faut faire entrer
l'école dans les lieux de travail c'est
à dire installer des classes partout où
on le peut dans les usines dans les
ateliers de ce que vous venez de faire
au maroc au maroc je suis allée la
semaine dernière il y a à Fès par
exemple une usine qui est exemplaire non
pas parce qu'elle emploie des enfants
mais parce qu'elle a décidé à signer un
accord avec le Représentant de l'Unicef
et les autorités locales et le patron de
l'usine pour premièrement ne plus
recruter d'enfants de moins de 12 ans
parce que pour le moment il y en a qui
ont 7 ans 8 ans deuxièmement ceux qui
sont là les scolariser trois heures par
jour et le patron de l'usine s'est
engagé à les payer de la même manière
c'est-à-dire à ne pas réduire leur
salaire déjà modestes très modestes
parce que elles sont scolarisés 3 heures
par jour
vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'Association Enfants et développement
alors vous avez une option qui
paraissait un peu iconoclaste mais qui
se rapproche finalement de ce qu'il
vient de dire Madame Brisset vous vous
dites surtout ne disons pas de travail
pour les enfants parce que ça peut leur
donner des situations bien plus graves
encore oui bonjour effectivement nous
avons une position maintenant tout à
fait proche de celle 2017 qui consiste à
dire que il faut éradiquer absolument le
travail des enfants quand il s'agit de
d'exploitation de choses dangereuses et
toxiques et abusives mais qu'on ne peut
pas c'est un problème très complexe
qu'on ne peut pas traiter
d'un seul d'un seul trait il faut
absolument arriver à
s'occuper de ses enfants à leur donner
la parole à écouter ce qu'ils ont à dire
ce que vous dites en quelque sorte c'est
que c'est facile vu d'Europe
occidentale de dire que finalement il
faut que les enfants de travail pas mais
vous sur le terrain vous dites ce serait
des décisions presque dangereuses
excessives que d'un seul coup dans lever
les enfants des usines ou des ateliers
parce qu'ils se retrouvaient dans la rue
et vous l'avez vu ça sont tout à fait
c'est des exemples assez fréquents
d'enfants qui travaillent dans des
ateliers où effectivement ils sont
exploités selon nos conceptions
européennes mais si on les remet dans la
rue parce que les fabricants du
Bangladesh ou dinde ou prennent peur
d'un boycott de produits dans lesquels
les enfants travaillent ils mettent ses
enfants dans la rue les remettent au
chômage et à ce moment-là les enfants
tombent dans des conditions
d'exploitation bien pires qui vont de
l'exploitation sexuelle à l'exploitation
au travail dans des conditions bien plus
horribles que celles qu'ils avaient
précédemment merci Monsieur cardio nous
voulions souligner cela c'est une
position qui nous chauffe pas Madame
Brice évidemment vous êtes sur la même
longueur d'onde mais il était important
de dire que ça paraît facile d'ici de
dire il ne faut pas que les enfants
travaillent il faut voir où il risque de
tomber également et ça vous en êtes
consciente
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'enfants
se retrouvaient dans la rue quand il y a
eu la proposition d'un sénateur
américain tendante à abolir l'entrée sur
le territoire des États-Unis ce qui
était fabriqué fabriqué par des enfants
c'est vrai que le risque existe mais ce
qui est très important c'est de ne pas
perdre le cap et le cap c'est
l'éradication interne et pour ça il y a
un instrument c'est l'école merci madame
je vais présenter votre livre Claire
Brisset donc dans la collection opinion
un monde qui dévore ses enfants donc
chez Liana Lévy je vais vous expliquer
fort bien de tout ce que vous venez de
résumer dans votre journal merci Madame